Freunde herzlich willkommen in diesem
wunderwunderschönen Ambiente ich darf
heute zu Gast sein bei einer besonderen
Frau bei einer echten italienischen
Nonna und die steht dir schon an der
Seite Nonna Miranda du kannst gerne zu
mir kommen freut mich sehr es ist mir
eine Ehre freut mich sehr ach ich freue
mich noch viel mehr danke ist schön komm
neben mich du möchtest mir heute ein
bisschen über die Geheimnisse von
italienischer Pasta verraten
Geheimnis glaube ich sind nicht viele
aber vielleicht vielleicht liegen die
Geheimniss auch in den einfachen Dingen
vielleicht in guten Zutaten das das
jedenfalls wir befinden uns hier am
gardersee wie man unschwer im
Hintergrund erkennen kann wir haben
wunderschöne Bergkulissen gleichzeitig
das blaue Wasser vom See befinden uns
unter Olivenbäumen und ich fühle mich
sehr sehr wohl nicht nur weil ich an
diesem schönen Ort bin sondern weil ich
auch Miranda an meiner Seite habe weil
ich glaube ich kann heute einiges lernen
über gute Pasta und wir machen natürlich
keine Pasta aus der Packung sondern wir
machen alles mit der Hand so du nimmst
jetzt ich nehme das
Mehl das ist wirklich wunderschön man
darf nie die Pasta machen nur für eine
Person zwei Person di Person für vier
Personen kann
man ein Loch eine Kuhle eine es ist
nicht kannst
im kein Vulkan wir sind nicht am wir
machen kleines Loch rein und ganzen Eier
hinein jetzt kommt ein bisschen von
einem guten Öl extra virgine von gardass
wisst ihr was das Besondere ist Leute
dieses Olivenöl was jetzt gerade zur
Pasta kommt kommt von diesen
Olivenbäumen das ist das extra Luxus
jetzt Miranda fangen wir an das Ganze zu
verquölen hast du gesagt oder einfach in
der Mitte und du musst nicht alles
machen lass dir ruhig Zeit ich bin da
ich mache das also wenn du willst h
jetzt jetzt okay es geht gut ich helf
dir ein bisschen
machen eine große Portion ein paar Mal
habe ich auch schon Pasta selbst gemacht
aber wie eine non Pasta machen dafür
braucht man die Erfahrung das kann man
nicht so improvisieren wann hast du
deine erste Pasta gekocht weißt du das
noch die erste Pasta vielleicht vor 50
Jahre hüntig ja das ist nicht schlecht
so jetzt kann man anfangen glaube ich
sobald das so ein bisschen bröselig wird
ne dann fängt man an das mit der Hand zu
machen Hand ja sowieso so jetzt
verkneten wir das Ganze und man merkt
wie das Mehl jetzt quasi von den Eiern
mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt wird und
sobald es verknetet ist Miranda ist es
schon fertig oder guck mal Max so macht
man das so macht man es richtig ja ja
ich merk schon konnt dir nicht mehr
zusehen wie du das machst ja ich weiß so
schlecht okay das ist gut jetzt ja bist
du zufrieden wirklich ja Bravo wir haben
eine schöne Oberflächenspannung ja ja ja
ja man sieht auch das Gelb komm sch das
muss man so schön streicheln so wenn wir
das einmal zugemacht haben was machen
wir jetzt würde ich sagen Deckel drauff
und warten 20 Minuten 20 Minuten bei
dieser Temperatur genügt wow das ist
wirklich ein traumszenario wenn ich
sowas sehe kriege ich los auch noch mal
irgendwie so für für ein halbes Jahr in
Italien zu wohnen oder so und so sieht
das ganze 20 Minuten später aus wirklich
schön geworden hast du eine
lieblingspasta wenn ich muss alle Tage
Pasta essen dann würde ich auch
Spaghetti aber nicht ganz zu dünne
Spaghetti am allerliebsten die Spaghetti
die was ein Loch haben in Bucatini weil
jede Soße besser sich verbindet genau so
dann zeig mir mal wie das funktioniert
das habe ich noch nie gemacht mit so
einem Nudelholz da da ist wieder ein das
Gefühl da muss man umdrehen dann wieder
so guck mal schau mal dass ich das
richtig mache Handballen und nach vorne
und nach hinten rollen oder so habe ich
gerade richtig gesehen be dann haben wir
die Paste auch schon gleich fertig das
ist schweißtreibend eine
schweißtreibende Aktivität schön
ausgerollt und man sieht schon das Licht
dadurch das ist glaube ich ein gutes
Zeichen wenige Minuten Rollen und dann
sind wir soweit oder
abolut jetzt kommt dieses besondere
Gerät hier ins Spiel ja das ist typische
da könnte man die bastaler Gitarre
machen das kommt da aus der das sieht
auch aus wie eine Gitarre oder so ein
bisschen wie eine Gitarre und die
ursprünglichen Spaghetti heißen nämlich
Spagetti
mus
[Musik]
ganz ach guck dir das mal
an das ist doch das ist herrlich so muss
es sein
oder wir haben es geschafft wir haben
das
geschafft und genauso machen wir das
jetzt weiter ich lege ein bisschen Pasta
auf unsere Gitarre drauf und so machen
wir das mit dem restlichen Teig damit
wir alles schon mal vorbereitet
haben
[Musik]
die Pasta ist vorbereitet und jetzt
möchte ich einen Klassiker von dir
lernen wie machst du Nonna dein
pestogenovese Basilikum wir haben
Pecorino wir haben Parmesan Knoblauch
grobes Salz und ein wenig Olivenöl mehr
brauchen wir nicht und zum allerersten
Mal mache ich jetzt oder machst du jetzt
Pesto im mer Schnittest die KN ja wir
machen das so ein fach nicht zu dünn
weil dann wird das so und dann ein
bisschen grobes Salz es wird dann ist
das Gewürz von die
basilikumum der Duft kommt dann zum Geld
soll wir das erstmal ein bisschen stoßen
ja oder bitte bitte bitte also wir haben
jetzt den Knoblauch und das grobe Salz
drin und zerstoßen das ein bisschen zu
einer Paste du hast die Blätter genommen
und dann hast du die jetzt so gedreht
genau nein wieso machst du das denn ja
we das ist so ich ist natürlich zu
machen ich kenne das wenn man bei einem
Cocktail z.B ein Minzblatt hat und das
einmal zusammenklatscht dann hat man den
Duft und dieser Trick den du gerade
anwendest wahrscheinlich bringt der den
Duft und den Geschmack weiter nach vor
man lernt immer man lernt immer ich lne
von dir ich lerne von dir so ist doch
schön jetzt gehen wir ein paar
penenkerne hier in unsere Pfanne du hast
einfach Sonnenschein vom garder sehr auf
den penenk wie soll die Pasta besser
schmecken als so ja ja ja ja man sieht
direkt schon wie ein bisschen Farbe
drant schon gehört von Pesto im m aber
ich habe es noch nie gemacht und ich
habe mich immer gefragt ob es ein
Unterschied macht würdest du sagen es
macht ein Unterschied großen untersched
einen ganz großen Unterschied das kann
ich garantieren gebe gebe hinein gebe
nicht sparen nicht sparen nicht sparen
aber jetzt glaube ich genug muss ein
gutes Gleichgewicht habenano regano darf
nie fehlen und dannin Romano der aus
Schar
oder hat
scharfetin ein bisschen
gewürziger geschmackvoller und jetzt
gehtb gibt jetzt gibt's das Gute
olivenmehl da darf man auch nicht sparen
mit Öl aber dieses olivenl
ist Gold man merkt jetzt richtig schön
wie das hier zusammenkmt bin echt froh
dass du mir das gezeigt hast Nonna weil
so habe ich noch nie Pesto gemacht danke
und jetzt sollten wir ein paar Nudeln
kochen oh und essen
oder Nudeln ja ja was wollen wir mehr
und das Wasser kocht auch schon hier
hinten guck dir das mal
[Musik]
an die erste Pasta ist fertig n noch es
ist doch wirklich ein Traum oder ich
glaube ein doppelter Trum wenn du 50
Jahre lang schon Pasta machst dieser
Moment ist immer noch schön oder immer
noch schön das glaube ich und jetzt S
wir probieren ob das auch schmeckt was
wir hier gezaubert haben aber mit deinen
Tipps bin ich mir fast sicher du bist
dir auch sicher oder ja wenn du das
sagst dann muss ich
glauben Leute ich weiß wirklich nicht
was es ist aber das ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich das Beste Pesto das ich jemals
gegessen habe die besten Nudel mit Pesto
die ich jemals hatte vielleicht ist es
der Mörser vielleicht ist es diese
wunderschöne Szenerie hier
wahrscheinlich ist es die Nonna die
gekocht hat und ich bin wirklich
gespannt welche Geheimnisse sie mir noch
verraten kann jetzt lernen wir ein
echtes Geheimrezept von der Nonna wir
machen Ragu all Bolognese also quasi
Ragu nach Bologna Art dazu brauchen wir
ein wenig Brühe dann ein sofrito aus
Staudensellerie Karotte zwiebel
Knoblauch einige polpa di Pomodoro also
Tomaten Fruchtfleisch dann gemischtes
Hackfleisch und Geheimzutat salzica dazu
noch ein bisschen Salz später bisschen
Parmesan ein bisschen Rosmarin sebei ein
Lorbeerblatt und ein schöner Rotwein
Nonna wie fangen wir an Öl in der Pfanne
das
dann machen wir ein bisschen Öl rein
nicht nicht zu viel sparen ja das habe
ich schon das gibt's in die die
deutschen Großmutter kochen auch gerne
mit viel Öl auf jeden Fall ja das kennen
wir alle auch wenn wir eine Suppe machen
boah so ein sofrito das riecht einfach
das riecht nach ich komme von der Schule
nach Hause und Mama hat gekocht das ist
eine normale sit was man hier in
Trentino im garderse also es wird
durchgeritzt und dann nehme ich die Haut
und jetzt gebe ich das verschierte
Fleisch es muss ganz heiß sein und jetzt
kommt das dazu einfach und jetzt kommt
das langsam wenn das Fleisch die sal und
alles ein bisschen anbrennt auf die auf
die Borden von von der Pfanne dann sind
wir am richtigen Punkt das ist richtig
dann können wir noch andere Gewürze
reingeben ich gebe
jetztmer Rosmarin schbei Spar ich ein
bisschen mit Salber Liebe nicht so
Salber aber ein
lobberblatt das habe ich irgendwo
gesehen das ist auch super im Ragu dann
komm das nie fehlen
war ein pa ein pa n das habe ich noch
nie gesehen ist ein Geheimrezept das ist
ein geheim das gibt ein eigenes Gewürz
das loberblatt rosmarin schalbei ist für
mich ja ein Blatt geht aber wichtig dre
VI
ich glaube jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt
erreicht noch bei dem wir schön
ablöschen können also eine gute
Flasche brauch ein
Gefühl wir warten jetzt bis der Wein
nicht getrunken verkocht trinken kommt
danach wenn wir ein schön wenn wir eine
schöne Bolognese haben dann dürfen wir
einen Wein trinken oder aber ja aber ein
gutes Glas Wein so und wenn das verkocht
ist was ist der nächste
Schritt ingeben verdünnt bisschen Brühe
Brühe sch wird tomatenmarke ein bisschen
bitter
so
so jetzt gebe ich das
tomatenm auch diese muss eine gute
Qualität sein jetzt kommt Tomaten in
Stücke fertig jetzt die hat jetzt noch
ein wenig Brühe drauf geschüttet und
ansonsten einf nur noch bis das weiter
kocht man kann schon fast sagen je
länger es kocht desto besser oder ja D
vi Stunden kochen aber ich bin ein
bisschen schneller du willst schneller
essen wir haben Hunger oder ja also
warten wir jetzt ein bisschen die Zeit
ist endlich gekommen du finalisierst
deine Bolognese jetzt mit dein Stück
Butter vielleicht sind nicht alle Fan
davon ja aber das ist meine Rez und
jetzt sieht man richtig wie schön das
hier reinschmilzt die Butter man hat
diese schöne Farbe und jetzt wird
umgerührt die Butter wird unter das Rago
gehoben und Verleih dem ganzen
wahrscheinlich noch mal so eine Note die
so bisschen herzhaft fettig ist aber das
ist einfach das ist das Gefühl mit dem
kocht nur eine
[Musik]
Nonna non na ich glaube wir haben uns
ein Glas Rotwein verdient oder zu diesem
wunderschönen Rago das wir gekocht
absolut was war das für ein schöner Tag
oder hier am gardersee und erst komm wir
stoßen erstmal an ich bin ganz
glücklichinin sagt man hier oder salute
der Wein schmeckt schon mal probieren
wir jetzt die tatelle AL RAG
Bolognese sind sie gut sind sehr gut
sehr okay schön alente die Soße ist so
intensiv reduziert und diese feinen
geschmacksnuten von der Nelke v la die
kommen wirklich gut durch und natürlich
haben wir ein Gard das schmeckt alles
besser Nonna vielen lieben Dank für die
Geheimtipps die du mir gezeigt hast weil
diese Bolognese und das Pesto heute sind
wirklich ein Traum danke danke danke
danke schön es hat mich sehr gefreut bei
dir zu Gast zu sein danke ich denke den
Zuschauern hat es auch sehr gut gefallen
wenn ihr wollt dass wir noch mal ein
Video aufnehmen gemeinsam dann schreibt
mal in die Kommentare okay dann ruft
mich R sehr gut wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dahin ciao
ciao ciao
[Musik]
ciao